now we got to show you some of the
ladies of the view they are thrilled
what an incredible day it was yesterday
as all this was unfolding for the insane
did we put the warning we put the word
put the warning again let's really drive
it home for the people
yeah it's the view here we go
and to quote the great Sunny Hosten the
twice twice in peace I can't even twice
a peach the twice impeached one term
once indicted but who's counting former
president is reportedly facing more than
30 count them criminal charges so how do
we feel about this unprecedented moment
in American history I called it did you
I feel good
begging for Applause
he would be held criminally responsible
because no one is above the law he would
be at the very least charged he not only
has the New York case he has a Georgia
case he has the Department of Justice
cases though there are two or three of
them there I mean you can't commit so
many crimes and think that you are above
the law even if you are the president
the audience you know that if the
audience of the view is not sure when to
applaud that you might be missing
something I think the audience is
actually smarter than them they are
thrilled that the guy that they hate is
potentially going down they don't care
why he's going down or what evidence
there is or isn't or as I'm talking
about here what this does to the fabric
of the country the amount of people who
feel that Trump was unjustly attacked
you know it's funny Joy Behar is talking
about two impeachments two impeachments
that nothing came of them the January
6th hearing that nothing came of it the
Mar-A-Lago raid that nothing came of
that like how many times again as Trump
said at the beginning in that first clip
they were going after him before he was
president with the Steele dossier and
everything else so all of these things
have systematically failed and they've
but because they went all in he's Hitler
we got to keep going and keep going and
keep going so now there the audience is
is being queued to applaud because they
don't even know what they're plotting I
think the audience might be going but
maybe this is just a bit much
[Music]
foreign